more than 14 000 health care
professionals have contracted the
coronavirus in the u.s and at least 27
have lost their lives in the service of
others one of them pamela orlando
documented her own fight with the virus
on camera
before she died lead national
correspondent david begno
has her story 56 year old pamela orlando
was a front-line hero this is a woman
who had everything to lose
and she still went out there on the
front lines saving lives the nurse from
new jersey
worked three jobs she was a breast
cancer survivor
and a single mom to 16 year old ryan
and 23 year old reed i begged my mother
to not go to work
i really did i begged her but that's not
who my mom was pamela worked at the
valley hospital
in ridgewood new jersey do you believe
your mother was infected at work
absolutely from home she started to
document
what would be the end of her life today
i have a fever that i can't get rid of
day two but where do i feel like
i can't quit for free back pain
fever that won't break by day three she
was hospitalized where she works
oh my god this is no joke i am so
uncomfortable
my fever just broke so a little bit
better
fever of 104.6 on the fifth day
i feel horrible
i'm like so bad like almost like i'm not
gonna make it
later in the day she was struggling just
to talk i can't even
[Music]
move without being short of breath just
pray
that i'm okay
pamela posted five more videos but she
didn't speak
she was trying to log every day of the
sickness to show the masses or whoever
would watch it
how this deathly virus can progress the
day she died
april 16th 24 days after she fell ill
reed and ryan visited her in the
hospital wearing proper protective
equipment
along with their 80 year old grandmother
ann who is pam's mom
she told my mom that she was going to
take care of us and really
protect us from anything and and that's
what my mother really needed
she needed to know that me and my
brother were going to be okay
56 year old pamela orlando died two
hours
after her boys went to see her gail
david that that video is so tough to
watch because you can actually see
her slipping away and what's painful to
me is she probably
knew she was slipping away but yet she
wanted to document this story
that in hopes of maybe helping others to
let people know as her son said how bad
this is
that's very tough to watch and i i can't
i feel for her sons
her sons who are watching this video and
who she was you know gail i spoke with a
friend of hers
who's a nurse at the hospital and she
said that every day she'd bring a phone
to pam's ear and she'd place it
by the ear and pam was on a ventilator
so she was unconscious but
every time the boys would talk her heart
rate which was beating rapidly would
drop considerably
and her oxygen levels would go up
notably
and so that was a sign to the friend and
the boys that pamela
could hear them loud and clear
yeah and i think about the medical
professionals too david who are now
treating their own
as a medical professional you don't
expect to end up a patient yourself in
most cases
and now many of them are in the
hospitals as well
thank you for sharing her story there
thank you for sharing her story
it was very difficult